parce que la politique se nourrit de
symbole en voici un deux poids lourds
des européennes
raphaël glucksmann manar aubry côte à
côte pour le débat le plus médiatique de
ce festival un festival qui a fait le
plein avec une quarantaine de débat et
un public unanime pour travailler à
l'unité d'une gauche divisée
ça c'est une grande idée effectivement à
laquelle on pense tous à laquelle tous
les courants de la gauche je pense est
effectivement
sinon c'est en va dans le mur on sait
très bien le grand sujet là qu'on vient
écouter un peu tout le monde pour savoir
si si enfin tout le monde va vouloir
s'entendre
enfin on a besoin d'eux de retrouver une
ligne de conduite de retour vers
l'avenir de retrouver un but
c'est plus qu'une nécessité c'est plus
qu'une nécessité aujourd'hui et c'est un
petit peu dommage de la voir dans un tel
état et si divisée
reste qu'au delà des idées que tout le
monde est prêt à confronter on voit vite
que les stratégies divergent avec un
lourd passif et déjà la perspective des
municipales de 2020 qu'est ce que la
gauche est ce que la gauche est celle
qui a fait le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi est ce que la
gauche est celle qui a proposé la
déchéance de nationalité
et puis qu'est-ce que ça veut dire unir
des appareils à l'heure où la vérité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les appareils
politiques sont décrédibilisés moi je
suis écologiste
donc ce que je veux c'est construire le
grand pôle écolo dans ce pays qui
rassemblera très largement très
largement issus de toutes les formations
politiques mais surtout issus de la
société les organisateurs ont en tout
cas voulu du concret un manifeste sera
adopté dimanche une forte de feuille de
route pour envisager un programme de la
gauche et des écologistes dans la
perspective de 2022
mais la route est encore longue